If you'd rather minimize the use
of any object all together,
you can provide information about
the contents of Objective C
collections when those arrays
are defined using lightweight generics.
For example, let's say we added
a property to our BookClass to represent
the awards that a book has one.
Each item in the array is a pointer to
an NSString representing the name of
the award.
We indicate that by placing NSString in
an asterisk between angle brackets
before the property name.
And here's what it looks like
when it's translated to Swift.
Notice that, instead of being an array
holding objects of type any object,
awards is an array holding
objects of type String.
We can also do this with dictionaries.
For example, we might have a property
representing a dictionary of quotes
about the book that are paired
with their source URLs.
Again, we indicate the types
held by the dictionary here and
between angle brackets.
And then,
if we look at the generated interface,
we can see that the swift version of our
quotes dictionary is holding keys of
type string and values of type NSURL.
Keep in mind that lightweight generics
are only supported for NS-array,
NS-set and its NS-dictionary.
They won't work with NS mutable arrays.